[Música]
en criminología estamos acostumbrados a
ver el mal del ser humano para que para
prevenir ese mal pero yo hoy aquí lo que
quiero traeros es un mensaje positivo no
sé si lo voy a conseguir lo primero que
tenemos innovación y delito que tiene
que ver la innovación con el delito
la pregunta que voy a tratar de
responder aquí es muy sencilla esta
tarde los cibercriminales innovan
los cibercriminales y los criminales
innovan existe innovación en la
delincuencia pero también existe
innovación en la persecución de la
delincuencia en la prevención de la
delincuencia y la última pregunta quién
va ganando porque tenemos un dicho que
es que siempre vamos por detrás del
delincuente siempre vamos por detrás del
criminal a lo mejor la innovación
tecnológica y digo a lo mejor porque al
final os tratare de desentrañar estas
estas preguntas nos va a decir lo
contrario pero antes de todo esto me
gustaría hacer con todos vosotros un
pequeño repaso a las diferentes
revoluciones industriales que hemos
tenido y qué ha sucedido con el mundo
del crimen porque también partimos de
otra premisa y es que la innovación
tecnológica las revoluciones
industriales las revoluciones
tecnológicas lo que han producido son
cambios en la sociedad y también en la
delincuencia si cambia la sociedad tiene
que cambiar la delincuencia qué sucedía
con la primera revolución industrial
pues lo más importante de esa revolución
industrial lo que podemos ver aquí
surgió el ferrocarril surgían medios de
transporte que hacía que estuviésemos
más comunicados
no es nada nuevo hacia dónde vamos hacia
dónde van nuestras revoluciones a estar
más comunicados aunque bueno en esta
última en la que estamos actualmente que
no sé si es la cuarta a la quinta
algunos dicen la cuarta aunque estemos
podamos estar más cerca de las personas
estamos un poco más lejos pero bueno ahí
no voy a entrar os voy a comentar otras
otras cuestiones si seguimos avanzando
en estas revoluciones encontramos que
también se internacionaliza se
internacionaliza las sociedades y se
internacionaliza también el crimen con
lo cual estamos hablando actualmente que
es hacia dónde nos dirigimos que estamos
en un crimen global en una delincuencia
global por qué porque la delincuencia es
global lo que he dicho las
modificaciones en la sociedad hacen que
también se vaya modificando esta
delincuencia pero otra cosa que me
gustaría mostraros aquí es toda esta
innovación está evolución que hemos ido
siguiendo ha hecho que seamos mejores o
peores ha hecho que tengamos mejores o
peores sociedades
en criminología igual que nos gusta
investigar el lado malo de las personas
que todos lo tenemos por cierto y todos
cometemos delitos aunque digáis que no
en ese en ese estudio del lado malo
nosotros nos basamos en datos nosotros
lo que queremos hacer es tener datos
para saber qué está sucediendo y unos
datos incontestables es el número de
homicidios que existen por 100.000
habitantes
si podemos comprobarlo con numerosos
estudios pues desde hace bastantes años
vemos que hemos disminuido una
barbaridad antes nos matábamos muchísimo
más eso en el nivel macro si nos vamos
un poquito más a ese nivel micro que ha
sucedido desde 1990 hasta la actualidad
en la mayor parte de estudios
encontramos que existe un claim drop es
decir la delincuencia está disminuyendo
la delincuencia contra la propiedad pero
sobre todo la delincuencia violenta en
las sociedades más avanzadas por decirlo
de alguna manera porque tenemos también
algunos lugares como pueda ser
latinoamérica que en los que estas
cifras pues bueno no nos indican no nos
indican lo mismo que sucede por ejemplo
en europa lo que sucede en norteamérica
pero también se han producido
en este periodo de tiempo también se han
producido disminuciones en cuanto a esa
delincuencia violenta en cuanto al
número de homicidios que es la primera
parte y el dato que me gustaría dejar
aquí para que después veáis que las
conclusiones pues tienen que ver dentro
de todo lo que os estaba comentando de
cómo evoluciona el delito cómo
evoluciona el crimen pues actualmente
estamos en un espacio que es el
ciberespacio donde también existe
delincuencia existe la ciberdelincuencia
y aquí se da una pequeña paradoja porque
resulta que en el ciberespacio tenemos
mayores oportunidades criminales porque
porque desde cualquier lugar del mundo
podemos cometer cualquier delito contra
cualquier persona que esté en otro lugar
no existe el tiempo no existe el espacio
los ciberataques pues podemos ser
víctimas de un ciberataque con un
que se ha diseñado hace 10 años en ser
víctimas ahora en este ciberespacio no
existe el tiempo no existen tampoco las
barreras es el lugar globalizado por
excelencia y si existe esa globalidad y
hemos trasladado
parte de la delincuencia a ese
ciberespacio pero lo que os decía de la
paradoja todavía tenemos cifras muy
bajas de ciberdelincuencia con respecto
a la delincuencia tradicional lo que sí
se ha producido y está aumentando en la
mayor parte de delitos es la
tecnificación de los delitos está
tecnificación de los delitos nos dice
que actualmente casi cualquier delito
que se produzca delitos violentos
delitos contra la propiedad existe algún
medio tecnológico existe algún tipo de
innovación que no existía hace tiempo y
que facilita esos delitos pero hasta
donde quiero llegar no es ahí sino el
mensaje positivo ya o se trasladó un
mensaje positivo no nos matamos menos
nos queremos un poquito más en una hora
pero también para poder prevenir el
delito y para poder perseguir el delito
tenemos numerosas herramientas tenemos
herramientas que antes no existían lo
primero que tenemos y esta es la
hipótesis que yo expongo aquí a raíz de
esta innovación tecnológica estamos
haciendo que exista menos delincuencia
no que se esté trasladando la
delincuencia del ciberespacio del
espacio físico tradicional
señor espacio sino que la innovación
tecnológica está haciendo que la
delincuencia también disminuya porque
porque tenemos estas herramientas
el crime mapping a través del mapeo de
los delitos ya estamos consiguiendo
adelantarnos incluso aquellas zonas
hemos empezado a conocer que el delito
no se produce de manera aleatoria sino
que se produce en algunos puntos
calientes por llamarlo así a través de
esta herramienta lo hemos empezado a
conocer y lo más importante podemos
hasta llegar a predecir y de hecho ya
tenemos estudios que nos dicen que lo
que puedan hacer diferentes algoritmos
están acertando más en esa predicción de
dónde se van a producir determinados
delitos de lo que puedan hacer los
analistas humanos pero bueno tampoco es
para ponernos nerviosos porque después
os comentaré algunas cosillas que tienen
que ver con esa interrelación entre las
máquinas y los humanos a la hora
del campo que estamos investigando que
es esa prevención del delito después
tenemos los social media tenemos todas
las redes sociales eso nos está
sirviendo para una cosa muy interesante
no sólo sirve para perseguir este delito
sino que sirve para prevenir el delito
de la manera más eficaz que conocemos
cómo se previene el delito de la manera
más eficaz a través de un control social
informal cualquiera de nosotros somos
capaces de prevenir el delito de mejor
manera que sucede con las redes sociales
tenemos numerosas aplicaciones que son
redes sociales por ejemplo en méjico que
van avisando de diferentes puntos en los
que hay balaceras
como lo llaman a y en los que hay
tiroteos y eso sirve para que podamos
prevenir la ocurrencia de estos delitos
a través de la utilización de estas
redes sociales por otro lado y una
cuestión que tenemos muy interesante y
muy importante que es todo el análisis
de big data toda la minería de datos no
sólo en el ámbito de la policía
predictiva no sólo en el ámbito de esa
predicción de la delincuencia que he
comentado antes sino tenemos
experiencias
es muy interesantes en el ámbito del
maltrato y acoso entre escolares en el
ámbito del bullying y del ciber bullying
que nos dicen que estos algoritmos con
los que se está trabajando a través de
diferentes proyectos son capaces de
detectar casos de bullying y
ciberbullying de una manera más precisa
que la que puedan hacer los tutores los
profesores esto no quiere decir que los
profesores no sean importantes sino que
simplemente dan una serie da una serie
de información que va a ayudar a
detectar este problema que es lo más
importante para que después se puedan
poner en marcha las diferentes medidas
que se crean oportunas y esto está
funcionando sabemos que está funcionando
en último lugar lo que tenemos pues es
todo lo relacionado con la
videovigilancia tenemos múltiples
estudios que han tratado de evaluar de
hecho nosotros estamos realizando 11
aquí que tratan de evaluar si está
videovigilancia es eficaz para poder
prevenir el delito lo que sabemos es que
si es eficaz en determinados delitos
aunque al principio pensábamos que no
era eficaz para prevenir delitos
violentos parece ser que ciertos delitos
violentos también se previenen a través
y videovigilancia con todo esto quiero
decir que esta innovación tecnológica lo
que nos está haciendo es que seamos más
eficaces en esa prevención del delito
esa es la parte buena que tenemos de la
tecnología y al final la tecnología nos
está ayudando en ese sentido pero sucede
otra paradoja os he dejado aquí varias
paradojas cuál es la última paradoja que
cuanto más seguros estamos más
percibimos que estamos inseguros es
decir menos percepción de seguridad
tenemos y esto es algo en lo que estamos
trabajando actualmente porque con
mayores cotas de seguridad percibimos
precisamente esa inseguridad y esto se
da sobre todo en personas que nunca han
sufrido un delito cuando les preguntamos
nos dicen son las personas que nos dicen
que piensan que tienen mayor
probabilidad de sufrir un delito o
aquellas zonas en las que menos delitos
se producen son precisamente las zonas
que cuando preguntamos cuando tratamos
de conocer qué es lo que sucede se
sienten más inseguras pero en definitiva
y para ir terminando lo que me gustaría
dejaros aquí la frase que me gustaría
dejaros es que a mayor innovación
tecnológica estamos teniendo una
de la delincuencia con lo cual pues
podemos decir que cada vez estamos nos
estamos convirtiendo en mejores personas
y por tanto en mejores sociedades muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]